so me out so now you're gonna end up
with a bullet in your hair for it you
can't play me mother [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ] that plays mother [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] cut Nigel that's great
oh it's smashing thank you so much yeah
well it's been an absolute honor and and
what a great opportunity to be here and
be able to play an American tough laughs
I'm just so glad that we got you out of
that BBC commitment so you can play with
us
Antoine listen I'm just not buying that
you're someone that was born and raised
in the streets of Brooklyn that's weird
because I actually was born and raised
on the streets of Brooklyn that wasn't a
gang and everything most of this stuff
actually happened to me
Wow okay well that's that's that's great
for us cuz I want you to use it okay
it's good first take let's just let's
get going it that's good let's get going
thank you - scene five take two and
action you sold me out son
now you gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me you can't play me
mother [ __ ] I'm the [ __ ] that
plays mother [ __ ] mother
[Music]
cut cut
okay uh Nigel that was great Oh
brilliant just really the way you move
especially when you talk I just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes cheers Cheers this fabulous
Antoine your performance it's just not
quite there yet okay I really need to
see you make more of a transformation
okay like like Nigel here that dude's
British yeah and if I might jump in with
a bit of advice I don't think I need
caramel maybe you might want to try
thinking of something in the material
that's similar to something that's
happened to no real life but for me for
instance I like to think of when me mum
wanted me to attend prep school in Leeds
to become a barrister but I wanted to
study the theater at Oxford thank God
and so that was a conundrum really for
me I must stop you right right there cuz
it's just confusing me right like I
don't need that cuz I am from the
streets I was in a gang they told me to
kill my cousin might be a bit spot-on no
yeah it's a bit spot-on
do you have any stories that involve
your mum what's the mum yeah scene five
take three okay antwuan remember you're
a gangster okay betrayal the streets
okay Nigel you're perfect and one
friends form and action you sold me out
son now you're gonna get AB lit up in
your hair for it
you can't play me mother [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ]
that plays mother [ __ ] is boring to
watch cut
that's not sound good and I do not feel
like you have found the emotional core
of this character man [ __ ] this nobody
is more real than me okay
I come from the streets and nobody's
gonna tell me what the streets is like
nobody you understand that's a great
speech I just wish that I believed it
you want to give it a shot
man [ __ ] this I'm as real yes yes
this [ __ ] is freezes for real I'm AB in
there man you are [ __ ] from the from
the [ __ ] from the are from the
streets from the start something today
no but I am so with I'm with you when
you say that even when you're saying the
wrong words I just wish you could do
that okay that hurts but I don't feel
that it comes from the right emotional
place for the character all right here
give it a shot give you what watch watch
that's great I feel that in here and in
here that aggression in my heart
you